[Music]  in this video we'll show you how to  predict images using vertex ai  from cloud console go to vertex ai  enable vertex ai api  click create data set  select cloud storage and specify the  file path the file includes the list of  over 3000 flowers with their names click  train new model specify auto ml in the  budget of 8 maximum load errors start  training  wait for about an hour click models  select the train model select deploy and  test tab click deploy to endpoint  specify endpoint name and allocate one  node for it click deploy  now open the blank presentation draw a  flower and create its screenshot image  upload the image the image was predicted  as sunflower with the confidence of  0.526  that's it to learn more about vertex ai  look at the links in the video  description  [Music]  you